rich is with us in Illinois hey rich
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I doing
Dave thanks for having me
you know I need some help oh yeah
there's another one on the way I have a
$25,000 Clara loan and a 15% increase
room I have $40,000 car loan at a 1.9
interest rate about six thousand dollars
and you know personal loans high
interest about one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in equity in the house
I need to get out of some of these loans
and clean some things up what's your
house holding right now Connor grand you
got a lot of you know too much car oh
yeah you probably need to sell so you
probably need to sell some cars they're
underwater they still need to sell I
mean how can you sell them but you have
to borrow the difference I mean you're
already $30,000 in debt if you sell it
you borrow five thousand now you're five
thousand dollars in debt but you know we
need a car though yeah so get a five
thousand dollar car I mean but you got
cars here that are absolutely insane
mm-hmm your cars on you well you got
twelve thirteen hundred dollars in car
payments
twelve hundred yeah they're eating your
lunch aren't they yeah well I'm not
eating much of anything but you know
yeah no I mean we needed a car but I
have money but you know yeah and so you
bought too much car but yeah but yeah
with a high interest rate was in the
bottom laughs and I'll shut about a
$5,000 car yeah no I know there's no
doubt about it but you know it is you
know the damage is done now it's just
trying to get out of the most of you
know each so what's the thirty thousand
dollar car what's it worth the you mean
a twenty five thousand record the one
that you said you owe 30 on what is it
worth no I will 40 on 140 and that's
yeah what's that what's that one worth
33 well carry 3,000 and who's that
stupid pot loan with that's with Ford
but that's a 149 interest rate so
there's not much interest going into
that payment you know what I'm saying
your comments on the point aren't you
probably 1.9% is not the problem
forty freaking thousand dollars is the
problem true the interest rate is not
your problem the problem is you bought
10x too much car because you were broke
and you financed all of it so you need
to go to the credit union and borrow
seven thousand dollars to sell that car
I'll borrow $10,000 and buy a three
thousand dollar car and get rid this
$40,000 car you dude that's you know
your problem is you got car fever you
know and you like these cars and you've
rationalized it in your head but there's
no way that these cars fit in your
income this is you know you these things
are tearing your butt off man every
month and so yeah you if I were you I
would get me into a couple of beaters
borrow the money and get out of the
difference and get out of these huge car
payments suddenly you're gonna have
money it's just gonna be amazing what
will happen if you do that I don't think
you're gonna do it but it's what you
should do
hey thanks for the call